dis moi en même temps que van gogh
il ya un double cd qui sort qui
s'appelle complètement dutronc c'est pas
toi qui a trouvé le titre quand même
bonne on a alors on se rend compte d'un
truc quand même quand on ré écouter des
disques maintenant que à l'époque les
johnny d sylvie tout ça il fait beaucoup
d'adaptations américaine et toi tu
faisais des chansons originales on se
rend compte qu'on a beaucoup parlé de
lanzmann mais quand il faisait des
musiques étaient formidables des vrais
riffs des vrais ils parlent que l'a1
c'est pesant retrouve en train de faire
des compliments pas mon genre mais tu
peux pas mais à l'époque tu avais le
fais pas tu avais le sentiment ou et
écrivait des truc con con et que des
mots mais coûtera encore maintenant où
tu faisais ça parce que tu donnes
tellement l'impression que tu fais ça en
rigolant dans photo c'est ça qui est
infernal ben je suis sûrement pas fermes
en foutant mais on rigolait ans
peut-être mais en tout cas je fabriquais
pas ça pour que les mômes de maintenant
disent tiens c'est pas mal il ya des
choses c'est comme les trucks et comme
les kings tu écoutais salle et pop3 ou
non les king's oui c'était chez vogue
ouais je payais pas les 10 l'arrêt tu
bosses et la bam
en plus j'y travaillais dis moi c'est
vrai que tu as promis un indice cac sony
pour 1992 promis je les signe sur allier
aujourd'hui il ya quelques années déjà
fait obligé de me faire enfin j'aime pas
le mot obligé parce que oui je vais le
faire mais tu travailles non tu pleures
travail coleman je crois pas non tu vois
pas en quoi c'est fini ça c'est pas que
c'est fini justement mais non je crois
pas cette fille françoise hardy non ce
qui est devenue top parolier armement
elle refuse de travailler pour moi de
toute façon
ah bon c'est le travail pour beaucoup de
gens au 8 mars à lc ces propos sont
quand même beaucoup plus sentimentaux
clemi ouais c'est vrai car tu sais pas
qui tu vas travailler la pâte et avec
moi alors